[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 97 it is am i
correct about that dr heinen you are
correct third time's a charm
it wasn't that charmed but uh no it
wasn't
that was not our wonderful producer's
fault actually we had asked him to turn
off the audio so that we could talk
beforehand but uh he's now saying it was
his fault isn't that amazing 17 year old
unbelievable yeah yeah we are not
trading him out for anything nope you
can't have him no
no he's uh he's a good one he's a keeper
as you say around here indeed
all right uh here we are man
a lot has happened much has happened a
lot has happened in the world and a lot
has happened in our world our book came
out on tuesday and we're going to be
talking
about it throughout the show today and
and some of some of how that feels and
has landed and is going to continue to
manifest but first we're going to start
with a few other logistics
three ads today and then we'll launch
right into the main part of the show so
um oh i guess i did want to say if
you've gotten the book and you've read
it please consider writing a review on
amazon uh and the reviews help us with
the algorithms and unfortunately we are
all um in thrall to some degree to the
algorithms resistance is futile
that is not the message of the book
resistance is not futile uh but um short
term uh we would like to uh not game but
accurately have the algorithms reflect
what people are saying to us privately
so if anyone has told you that
resistance is futile pick up a copy of
our book to see a well-reasoned
counterpoint excellent
um we're streaming on both odyssey and
youtube try it out on honesty that's
where the chat is happening
uh we've got quest q a which will happen
in the hour after this one we'll you can
ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we've got patreons which we encourage
you to join as well right now on my
patreon is the the 48 hour period during
which you can ask questions uh that we
will
try to address as many as possible in
the monthly private q a those that
question asking period is open right now
and um
yeah maybe we'll maybe we'll stop there
for now we will do three ads and then
get right into it fair enough
[Music]
okay
our first sponsor
our first sponsor for this week is a new
one to us it's md hearing aid
while neither of us has used this
product that's md hearing aid
while neither of us has used this
product we asked a friend with hearing
loss to try it out and we'll share her
testimony below but everyone can
empathize with what it feels like to be
left out of a conversation others are
enjoying or to need to crank the volume
up on a show beyond what other people
need those with hearing loss
suffer an invisible set of harms
invisible quite literally to those of us
without without it so md hearing aid is
an fda registered rechargeable hearing
aid that costs a fraction of what
typical hearing aids cost
the average price of hearing aid in
america is 2 400
but their vault plus model is just 299
dollars each when you buy a pair
mt hearing aid md hearing aid was
founded by an ent surgeon who saw how
many of his patients needed hearing aids
but couldn't afford them he made it his
mission to develop a quality hearing aid
that anyone can afford
they aim to fit so well that no one will
know you're wearing them they're
rechargeable with a battery life that
lasts up to 30 hours they're water
resistant and up to three feet of water
and you don't need a prescription or a
doctor's appointment you buy it directly
from them where audiologists and
licensed hearing specialists are
available seven days a week
md hearing aid has knocked the price
down on hearing aids by recognizing that
about 95 of people who need a hearing
aid only require a few settings so they
simplify the need for certain components
not needed by most people and they cut
out the middleman that's how the price
is so low
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers and they offer a 45-day risk
free trial with 100 money-back guarantee
so here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who we had md hearing aid shipped
their product to she tried it out for a
little while
and she relies on hearing aids herself
we asked her to try this product and she
said
quote with my particular type of hearing
loss and deep male voice in a noisy room
was the hardest situation for me to hear
and understand speech
i wore the md hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced man in a
room with a lot of white noise md
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars i was amazed at
how effective they are
end quote
so go to mdhearingaid.com and use promo
code darkhorse to get their buy one get
one 299
each offer
plus they're adding a free extra
charging case 100 value just for
listeners of dark horse so head to md
hearing aid.com and use our promo code
darkhorse or you can even call them at
833-772-1392
all right our second ad
our second ad
which i will also be bringing you before
we switch to brett is for four sigmatic
which we've talked about before that's
four f o u r sigmatic um it's a wellness
company known for its delicious mushroom
coffee i know that sounds weird and kind
of off-putting it certainly did to me i
was skeptical myself but i've been
drinking it lately most mornings and
it's really really good you i i like it
too yeah i i forced some on you this
time and you liked it too
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with lion's mane mushroom for
productivity and chaga mushroom for
immune support
it adds a little something some
crispness and focus in my experience the
world seems just a little more clear
after drinking it it's delicious just
like regular coffee you can't taste the
mushrooms if that's what you're worried
about as i was but it tastes just like
your favorite coffee dark nutty and
delicious
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten free plus every single
batch is third-party lab tested to
ensure its purity and safety so you know
you're getting the highest quality
coffee and mushrooms possible
it's got over twenty thousand five star
reviews backs their products with a
hundred percent money back guarantee
and we have an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee this is just for dark horse
listeners get up to forty percent off
plus free shipping on mushroom coffee
bundles to claim this deal you must go
to four sigmatic f o
you'll save up to 40 and get free
shipping again so right now go to f o u
r s i g m a t i c dot com
dark horse and fuel your productivity
and creativity with some delicious
mushroom coffee
awesome all right dyslexia be gone
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for everyday essentials
their ingredients are carefully sourced
high quality and affordable public goods
has towels glassware and sponges razors
and shampoo and toilet paper mustard and
coffee and coconut oil they've got niche
items like bone broth concentrate and
gluten-free pasta and small batch
marshmallows we've tried several of
their products and have yet to be
disappointed
public goods cares about health and
sustainability for its customers and for
the planet they plant one tree for every
order placed and the ingredients are
ethically sourced their products are
largely free of harmful ingredients
public goods products have a great
design too the aesthetic is simple and
clean there are no garish colors like
for example imagine perfectly clear dish
soap
i don't want products that i use to draw
attention to themselves so public goods
is a great fit
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store for dark
horse listeners we have the following
offer receive 15 off your first public
goods order with no minimum purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again that they're giving
you 15 to spend on your first purchase
go to publicgoods.com
darkhorse
use the code darkhorse at checkout that
is spell it out he said saying the quiet
part out loud
publicgoods.com p u b l i c
o
dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15 off your first order
scared you didn't i
no no that was good all right yeah
i think we're beyond you scaring me with
things like that yes indeed indeed
there's there's much scarier things of
foot in the world frankly right which
actually um this brings me to something
i was going to say this is now a perfect
segue
you have cautioned me sometimes when i
have warned that winter is coming that
maybe that's not the best thing to say
to people that it's a bit uh
dark and foreboding and i believe i have
come up with a solution oh good um i
think it is very important that people
be warned but you're right that may be a
little precipitous and so what i'm
thinking is autumn is coming
right because it is right and you know
the it is the equinox is a frightening a
frightening development and there's
nothing we can do to stop it it's it's
not a frightening development i've
actually i've been thinking about the
equinox
i figured you had
i've been thinking about the equinox and
the fact that this year it comes right
about at exactly a full moon as well
which is which is
um you know not meaningful
in
in most senses except it also happens to
coincide with the day that i will be
making my next post on natural
selections my substance newsletter so
i've been thinking about the ways in
which
the equinox is a deeply meaningful time
of the year
in terms of the days being equal length
and changing very very rapidly much more
rapidly
day length that is photo period changes
much more rapidly around the equinoxes
than it does at either solstice
but it would have been
the actual equinox would have been very
very difficult for the ancients to
identify precisely right as opposed to
the moon
right so you know the the phase of the
moon is a giant sky clock
um in in many ways and you know to for
sure it's a giant sky calendar and if
you understand the ways that it
processes um also also to some degree
o'clock but the equinox while
very important for things like um
planting and harvest and such um is a is
going to be much less precisely used by
ancient people than than things like
moon phases um because
cloud cover not withstanding cloud cover
will change this but in general you can
see the moon's phases and it's very hard
to get precise on the equinox it is
difficult to get precise um
there are of course
these physical clocks installed by many
cultures around the world that allow
them to figure out where they are not by
calculating but by the you know the sun
sets in this notch in the building uh at
uh the solstice or the equinox and so
there's an amazing one of these at inga
right beautiful one in fact uh maybe
i'll dig up a photo and that can be our
um
our thumbnail for this episode
but
sorry inga perka being um ecuador's
largest incan ruin the inca not having
gotten that far north um until
relatively late you know so they were
only the inca were only in what's modern
day ecuador for 80 years or something
less than 100. and um the place that is
now called incoperca was a place where
the kenyari people lived and the inca
kept trying to abolish you know
obliterate them and they failed and so
what often happens in these cases when
one one population does not simply
trounce the other is a royal marriage
was arranged and this incoperca became
for you know the 80 years or so before
the spaniards came and changed
everything um basically a combined
kanyari and incan stronghold and city um
which has one of these um these sun
clocks
physical clocks yeah um
there's a primitive one of these in the
uh in the midwest
where
the beauty of it i've forgotten exactly
where it is but the beauty of it is that
they tripped over how to calibrate the
thing um and so they ended up having to
keep re-digging it and
adjusting it because it was off slightly
and it would get worse and worse as the
years progressed but anyway this this
goes to this really interesting point
which i don't know this yeah it's is
this is pre-columbian people oh yes yeah
yeah um but anyway i i've always sort of
thought that the fact that the solar
system does not work um as a function of
integers that there are you know that a
year is not an exact number of days for
example which causes a calendar that's
really close to right to get worse and
worse over time that this is um
about the best proof we've got that the
universe was not constructed
intentionally by a loving god it could
have been constructed by a malevolent
god
or no god but a loving joke after god
well a jokester god who wanted your
harvest to get less and less effective
over time as your clock revealed its
imprecision
but anyway yes these celestial events
are really important and the number of
cultures who've figured out the answer
by not having to calculate it and
therefore not having to deal with these
fractional issues but empirically you
know it settles in that notch and that's
how we know we're back at that place in
the calendar yeah um is is the right way
to do it if you don't have um a really
sophisticated model absolutely
absolutely great
um okay so
yom kippur was this week
and it is the highest holy day in the
jewish calendar
a time traditionally of atonement often
associated with the fast
and
i don't have much more to say about that
except by way of segway to saying
hanukkah is not a high holy day in any
way in the jewish calendar um but but we
being from uh you know
we
are a secular household who come from
different religious traditions
and um
and we you know we celebrated a secular
level both christmas and hanukkah in our
home
and we have adopted a new tradition
associated with hanukkah which makes up
the epilogue of our book a one-page
epilogue so while we are not going to
continue to do excerpts from the book
going forward we you know we were doing
one a week per chapter um for the 13
weeks before the publication but the one
page epilogue
i think will make for fodder for
discussion for a little while right so
we have effectively felt some license to
tinker with hanukkah it being a lesser
holiday um and
uh our household being a non-traditional
one and so anyway what we've done is uh
in a sense a prototype we have tried to
make it meaningful in a way that uh
grows with us as the years pass and
anyway heather's about to introduce it
to you yeah absolutely um so i'll read
through them and then we'll just we'll
talk a little bit about either each of
them or whichever ones we feel like
so epilogue to a hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century
tradition and how to tweak it
in our home one of our annual rituals is
to celebrate hanukkah the jewish
festival of lights that occurs just
before or around the northern winter
solstice we light the menorah as is
traditional and each night review an
additional principle which is not
our family's new hanukkah rules so again
there are eight days of hanukkah if we
haven't said that there are eight new
hanukkah rules day one
all human enterprises should be both
sustainable and reversible
day two the golden rule do unto others
as you would have them do unto you
day three only support systems that tend
to enrich people who have contributed
positively to the world
they four
don't game honorable systems
day five one should have a healthy
skepticism of ancient wisdom and engage
novel problems consciously explicitly
and with robust reasoning
day six
opportunity must not be allowed to
concentrate within lineages
day seven precautionary principle when
the costs of an action are unknown
proceed with caution before making
change
and day eight society has the right to
require things of all people but it has
natural obligations to them in return
so should i go through one by one or or
what do you what do you think here um
whatever you think i mean uh i always
like revisiting them i look forward to
hanukkah and the um the celebration of
these things and what we do you know we
whatever dinner we're having that night
we don't have you know special eight
nights of hanukkah dinners but um we
discussed that principle
uh around the dinner table with our boys
as well
um so okay the first one
all human enterprises should be both
sustainable and reversible and i think
that that reversible word is the thing
that is often missing from discussions
of sustainability
and um and is often missing in sort of
more naive discussions of what it means
to be a liberal versus a conservative
you can you can be all in for progress
but not be interested in making change
if um that change is going to be
permanent
yeah and it really it's an attempt to
fix the precautionary principle which
anybody who has tried to to figure out a
way to operationalize the precautionary
principle realizes that it it's very
difficult to do right because you know
what um
if you interpret it very strictly it can
paralyze you and what we don't want is
to paralyze us we want to be able to
take advantage of you know
reasonable risks but we very frequently
find out that risks we thought were
reasonable turn out not to have been and
so the reason to talk about
reversibility
is that
if you make a change based on a
reasonable guess that the consequence of
it will be safe
and you
you do something that cannot be undone
if you turn out to be wrong you're
actually taking a much bigger risk than
if you've said well what we need to do
is build up the capacity to undo this at
the same scale that we have built the
capacity to do it right so the point is
you know at the first the first moment
that you invent an automobile that uh
burns fossil fuels and makes co2 you are
altering the atmosphere but you're not
obligated to do anything about it at
that level it's such a tiny alteration
that it's not significant
but at the point you ratchet up the
capacity to burn fossil fuels so that
you do start changing the chemical
composition
of the atmosphere you're taking a risk
that you'll change the heat trapping
capacity and so therefore you need to
build up in tandem the capacity to undo
it if need be and if you haven't done
that you find yourself where we are now
which is we've got to change it is out
of our control and it threatens to
trigger a positive feedback in
in the arctic with the frozen uh methane
being released the so-called clathrate
gun hypothesis
but um
if if we had recognized the need to be
able to undo changes to the atmosphere
at the same rate that we changed the
atmosphere then the point is at whatever
point we discovered that this had been a
mistake we would already have on hand
the solution
absolutely
um
day two is the golden rule do unto
others uh do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
uh you know
classic of course not um
not something that generally shows up um
in a jewish holiday wow but uh you know
modern you know modern judaism obviously
in encompasses the golden rule as do all
moderns and it has been invented
multiple times including rabbi hillel
has a prior version of what we now call
the golden rule and so the point is
societies that work have figured this
out as a basic principle and
it is really important that it be uh
understood even you know again
the devil is in the details with all of
these things about operationalizing them
but right and then and they're they're
good
they function as single sentence uh
prescriptions
in which you need to understand that uh
you know conditions will vary and will
affect to what degree you should
uh attempt to make these real yeah
uh so
let's see um only number three only
support systems that tend to enrich
people who have contributed positively
to the world
and i guess i would add to that day six
opportunity must not be allowed to
concentrate within lineages
right the
the idea that we should you know
recognizing that we cannot actually
achieve complete equality of opportunity
um because
because conditions vary
but we should be seeking to maximize the
quality of opportunity absolutely as
much as possible for all human beings
and part of the way that we will do that
is
to
to
to spread the opportunity across
lineages
and also to ensure that those who are
profiting from um from doing ill in the
world uh profit as little as possible
yeah
this the point you know throughout the
book basically we're pointing to the
fact that we live in an evolutionary
system and in an evolutionary system
where you profit by externalizing harm
on to others that behavior will spread
and be elaborated in a system where
externalizing harm on to others is
costly that uh
behavior will dwindle which is exactly
what you want and really the question is
you've either built a system that
involves in a direction that's positive
or you've built one that evolves in a
direction that's negative and you know
how well you built it will adjust how
quickly it moves in those directions but
the real question is trajectory which
which way do you want to go and i think
i mean this is this is a good time
probably to
remind most of the audience hopefully
but inform some
of uh the idea that
to identify something as an
evolutionarily stable strategy to
identify that something has
uh has
has been promoted by selection and is
thus gaining ground is in no way to
suggest that it is either a good thing
or a moral thing or that all conditions
would uh result in that being a stable
strategy so there will for most for many
things be multiple evolutionarily stable
strategies and when conditions change
either endogenous or exogenous um the
suite of environmentally stable
strategies will change as well and i'm
reminded actually one of the um one of
the podcasts we did this week about the
book uh was the realignment and i think
i think that's actually out now um a
really nice conversation we had and um
we ended up talking a little bit about
the
misapprehension that so
much of modern academic social science
has about what evolution actually is
that
especially i think sociology and
anthropology have actually taken the
sort of the social darwinist the
eugenics uh version of what um
evolutionary biology is and imagine that
that's what all of us who are trying to
explain the world to evolution are doing
and it's it's absolutely a hundred
percent
wrong right so what
what things like eugenics imagine um is
that survival of the fittest is both a
stable state in which whatever is most
fit right now is most fit forever and
ever and also that um things like wealth
are good indicators of fitness and of
course in markets where you have things
like opportunity having concentrated and
lineages the fact that you were born
wealthy may have say absolutely nothing
about your ability to accrue goodness in
the world nor is wealth inherently a
good indicator of that
but more to the point is the idea that
there is no
stable survival of the fittest
everything in evolution is context
dependent and as the environment changes
so too
does what the what the appropriate
measure of fitness might be
so i want to refine one thing here
wealth is not a good indicator of
fitness in any meaningful sense it may
lead to fitness in other words your
wealth gives you power to
you know protect your family and things
like that but um it is not indicative of
the fact that you have brought something
special to the table but it should be
right we should want markets that cause
that effect where wealth actually is an
indicator of having provided some real
benefit rather than having externalized
harm
um so
one you know we've been very deliberate
in constructing these principles and so
the phraseology is often precise for a
reason and note that we say opportunity
shouldn't be allowed to concentrate in
lineages right that is not the same
thing as saying wealth now obviously
there's a degree to which wealth can
accumulate within lineages that is very
destructive in large measure because it
leads to opportunity and so to the
extent that the wealth is all
concentrated and that means that people
who might be able to do something useful
which should be rewarded don't have the
opportunity because either they don't
get the educational benefits or they're
too preoccupied sustaining themselves
but that's a bad thing and this and this
is the wise version this is the informed
version of what um activists talk about
when they talk about privilege
right and and so the point is there is a
there is a real critique in there one
needs to be really careful i you know
the more i think about it the less one
wants a world in which the um
the product of productivity in which our
gains are evenly distributed that's a
desperately unfair world and it doesn't
do good things and um you know this is
the the failure at the heart of
communism but there is an enlightened
version of well what do you want to
equalize and the thing that i think
separates these two things is if you if
you're a believer in markets right as we
are if you're a believer in markets
then they work best when everybody has
access to them right meaningful access
not just theoretical access but when
everybody has the tools to actually
innovate and bring things into a market
then the things that's just access at
the consumer level right right it's that
not just access at the consumer level
which all americans have
pretty much but access potentially at
the producer level right that's the most
important thing and so if you have a
market that rewards things that are
actually positive that actually create
meaningful wealth rather than transfer
wealth
um then uh
the reward uh arising because you've
innovated the opportunity has to be
spread most widely because then we get
the maximum
number of opportunities to evaluate and
the good ones rising then results in a
reward and
that's how you get a system that evolves
to meet the values that we claim to hold
rather than one that is constantly uh
running up against those values
that's right
let's see don't game honorable systems
uh
maybe we've done that already but well i
would we have a game the honorable
system no we don't maybe we've talked
about yeah i will just say sometimes
with customer service you have to be
ruthless
uh customer service there's really good
chance customer service is not an
honorable system that's why it's written
that way yeah exactly
um but i mean this is this is one of the
things and we you know we have this in
the epilogue not in the end of either
the childhood or the parenting
relationship chapter but um this is one
of the messages that we were teaching
our children very very early and you
know all of all of these we were um
giving to our children every year you
know with hanukkah but um the idea that
uh for instance uh we as their parents
have rules that they may not understand
but they are they are
honorable they are intended to be good
and sometimes we will make errors
and when we make errors we are expected
to figure it out and change them or to
have or to respond to them when they
figure it out and change them but the
idea that they would game us and this is
true for any um parent-childhood
relationship um if the parent is a is a
good parent is a good and loving parent
as all parents should be but of course
not quite all are
um
their systems their rules that they have
in place no matter how good they are
if they're honorable should be refinable
over time and that is much much harder
if the child is simply reacting to oh
it's a rule um i don't like it and this
is this is unfortunately a place where
we have lost nuance in the modern in the
modern world among especially um some on
the on the sort of what i call the
pseudo left the idea that
if it's a rule if it's a law if it came
from the before times whatever that
means it must be bad
is absurd and you know some of what
we're being handed down right now is bad
and is dishonorable and um and is not
worthy of being protected things like
customer service maybe in some cases but
um
but the idea that for instance the
founding principles on which uh the
united states were um were based um
they're to some degree outdated they're
not as up to the task as they should be
anymore but they are deeply honorable
and they have been deeply functional
actually it strikes me um so in the book
uh we talk about the precautionary
principle and chesterton's fence which
turn out to be inverse of each other and
i'm thinking actually
that there's another one of these about
how one addresses um
a dishonorable system a system built to
do uh harm or to
give control where it doesn't belong
and that it's the flip side of what we
say about immoral orders right you have
an obligation not to follow immoral
orders and you have no obligation to uh
treat a dishonorable system as if it
were an honorable one
um and uh yeah this is good yeah civil
disobedience and immoral orders are the
flip sides of each other i guess uh
yeah yeah or the response to immoral
orders yeah exactly
um
day five one should have a healthy
skepticism of ancient wisdom
and engage novel problems consciously
explicitly and with robust reasoning so
this is kind of this is a twofer really
um it is it is both a
um that which came before um has worked
if it's been persistent and complex and
long-lived persistent long-lived being
um synonyms here um but that doesn't
mean that it's up to today's challenges
um but that also doesn't mean that you
throw that out and just take whatever is
new as an appropriate response yeah and
so uh the second to last chapter of the
book is really about this puzzle it's
not that we don't like ancient wisdom we
love ancient wisdom but the point is the
more rapidly your situation is changing
the less likely that wisdom is to apply
and so the skepticism isn't like
it's not cynicism about ancient wisdom
it's a you have to evaluate each of
these parameters and whether they fit
our current circumstances because
uh
you know
how do you apply
you know the
moral tenets of the bible to twitter
right you know with
bots and
multiple anonymous accounts and
de-boosting i mean you know yeah the
good samaritan gets slaughtered
right so we have we have to think about
these things and you know very
frequently the formulation that we
arrive at is you've got a value which
motivated a
prescription from the past the
prescription goes out of date the value
doesn't and the question is well how can
you
do how can you
protect that value in the present
circumstance without obligating yourself
to a prescription that's inadequate
absolutely
very good
um
okay we already did the next two so the
final one is day eight society has the
right society has the right to require
things of all people but it has natural
obligations to them in return
this is um this is one about which
people will disagree um i mean people
may disagree with all of them but i
think the idea that society actually has
a right to require things of us
uh is
is something that many find anathema
but
it is true
as long as the contract is a good one
yeah let's put it this way it has to be
true there are too many of us who can't
all decide to go hunt and gather and say
i i reject uh being part of civilization
i'm going to go back and do what i was
born to do if you if you do that
right the the earth will not be able to
sustain our population it'll crash so
the point is we've actually signed you
up
um for civilization and you can't opt
out of it right you can't go claim
territory or whatever else you might
have done in the past we pay taxes and
we get licenses in order to drive and
and such right however the point is that
naturally comes with the obligation that
the society that robbed you of your
right to go do what you feel like doing
has to protect you from certain things
right it has to protect you from the
predatory behavior
of powerful entities you know for
example well if it's an intact social
contract it's not theft it's not having
been robbed right right well the point
is you didn't have a choice but to sign
it you were born into a society and
you're obligated to be part of it um but
that comes with obligations and the
problem for us moderns typically
is the thing
is in breach of contract
right the systems that are supposed to
protect us and are supposed to provide
the opportunity that was the thing that
we got in exchange for giving up our
right to go hunt and gather right
those that capture is now predatory and
it takes advantage of us and so the
problem is the society is in breach of
contract and that changes our
obligations
to it
that's right
um
you wanted if that wraps up that little
section uh you wanted before
before i had some more stuff to talk
about you want to talk about pegasus
spyware yes i do which i know nothing
about i only knew enough to say it i'm
going to tell you a little bit about it
so pegasus spyware has been in the news
you may have just had your
apple iphone
update itself
pegasus spyware is apparently a
uh a spyware program that was loaded
onto my understanding is virtually every
iphone ipad mac
i watch in existence
when
well that's i'm gonna get there okay so
this program
was essentially a back door and it was a
zero click
exploit which means in the past you
might have gotten
an email that you would have to open an
infected file in order for your computer
to be infected so a person could be
careful and not click things from people
they didn't know or files that looked
funny in this case that was not true the
file could land in your computer or your
iphone and the exploit could be
delivered and this exploit which was
created by an israeli company the nso
group a very cryptic entity
allowed
access to
your email your phone calls your text
messages could apparently allow
uh
your camera and microphone to be turned
on without your knowledge
now i would just point out
if
your neighbor figured out how to do this
to your phone or your computer right
your neighbor was just curious about
your life and they figured out how to
use your computer in order to spy on you
they looked through your email your text
messages and all that stuff
you
would be beyond irate right this is such
an incredible invasion of privacy
to have a private entity set up the
conditions for this and then apparently
sell access to the data of individuals
to their enemy enemies and competitors
right they sold access to the devices of
for example
activists to the governments
that opposed them right this is such an
asymmetry right the activists would have
had no mechanism for buying the same
information
about government officials this is just
a completely asymmetrical
mechanism for preventing
change right
so this exploit existed they got it onto
the the majority of apple devices
they then sold access to enemies of
people i would point out the reason i
wanted to raise this is that i think we
have to start asking the question
how much effect has this had on recent
history how much effect does this have
on what we think is true
right
how many of the people who might have
been telling you some uncomfortable
truth have been unable to do so because
their enemies knew all sorts of things
about them that prevented them from
reaching the position they would
otherwise have ended up in it's a very
difficult question and we don't know the
answer what we know is
how
how is the answer even knowable i don't
think the answer is knowable the answer
is not knowable right in fact we got a
patch that just got delivered over the
air that uh eliminated this malware but
okay so we know maybe well
maybe is one thing but also how many
others are there so we know about
pegasus are there other exploits like
this that are lurking in our devices if
you said well my goodness i can't
believe that apple allowed this to
happen uh i'm gonna get a different
phone well okay now you're in google's
universe right so
there doesn't seem to be an escape
right there are ways that you can do
other things there are
uh phones that have been de-googled and
things how good a protection is that
uh it's a little hard to say but
we're stuck in this paradigm where the
exact things that we know are necessary
for progress the ability for people to
talk with each other the things that are
protected in our constitution for
exactly this reason right they can't
stop you from gathering with other
people and talking to them and saying
what needs to be said and it doesn't
mean that what's said is necessarily
good or right but we have to protect
that right in order for history to work
all right and so we are we're losing
this and it's and it's barely noticed so
what i discovered in researching pegasus
in advance of this podcast
that apparently pegasus isn't even new
right malwarebytes reports you want to
show the malware
bytes
link that i sent you
malwarebytes which is uh an industry
um group they sell anti-malware products
says that this isn't even new that
they've
known about this since 2016. so i can't
see the data on this article this this
article is new and responsive to the
current wave of the current wave which
was triggered by a a privacy group
having analyzed the phone of a dissident
who had had his phone infected
or not just infected because apparently
they were all infected but exploited
right and so how does a person come to
know that their phone has been exploited
well that's just the thing is apparently
there's some group of 50 000
phone numbers that have
had special access gained maybe 10 000
have been actively surveilled but we
don't know what those numbers are and
they're you know
it isn't easy i i did encounter there's
some mechanism that an infected phone
there's a mechanism you could um
back it up to a computer and then do
some command line work with a tool to
see if the files that would be generated
in the functioning of this exploit are
present right but that's first of all
that's not a simple thing to do right so
most people will just simply not know
likely your phone got updated without
you even knowing what was going on
so the evidence may be gone but
for god's sake this is just this is an
incredible moment where
we
i mean for one thing look we all have
this person in
our life or we are this person who says
if we're going to talk about important
things maybe the phones shouldn't be in
the room maybe we should put them in the
fridge maybe we should go take a walk
right we all have that person and we all
think that's probably just
it's got to be unnecessary right
it's true we now know that that thing is
there and if you're talking about stuff
that doesn't change the world it
probably doesn't matter and if you're
talking about stuff that does change the
world then you got to ask yourself the
question is somebody going to listen in
are they going to figure out what i do
understand and what i don't understand
are they going to figure out who i
suspect and who i trust and play us off
against each other like a fiddle i mean
i think getting back to your point about
the neighbor if a neighbor did this it
would be clear
to everyone why this is totally
unacceptable and the idea that it's an
anonymous
company
that may or may not
be doing it should in fact give us no
comfort i would say it's quite the
opposite at least at least a neighbor is
a real person who could be talked to
whatever nefarious purposes they might
be up to um but there's no there's no
reasoning with an abstract entity
that has uh made a move on it sounds
like at least tens of thousands uh if
not you know well more than that of
people and their and their devices
and um there's just there's there's no
accountability and there is no to go
back to our earlier point
um
reversibility
in that once this thing has been
breached as malwarebytes is saying has
happened as has been true for a long
time
now that this capability exists it will
continue to exist there's no going back
to a world in which this capacity does
not exist right you would have to you
would have to build for it and
you know yeah there's no question no one
that's a possibility if you if you
compare the neighbor having done this to
you to some anonymous murky security
corporation in some
foreign state there's no question that
the neighbor
is a far better scenario as infuriating
as that is right to have a
an economic entity gain access to your
phone and then be able to sell it to
your enemies is just so troubling yeah
well i mean at some level this is also
consistent with a theme that we've
heard ourselves talking about over and
over and over again with regard to the
benefit of engaging with physical
reality and physical space over entirely
social reality or in this case abstract
reality where um i think it may not have
ever been said by whoever it was
attributed to but the idea that good
fences make good neighbors you know
somehow that's apocryphal but um good
fences might make it it's not apocryphal
but the the poem means the roughly the
opposite of what people think about
that's that's right yeah um but
um the fact is that fences are a reality
and fences can be built and if you do
have a neighbor who is spying um you can
actually erect physical things and you
can't talk to the person
whereas there is neither nothing to
erect except with similar tools which
most of us don't have access to nor is
there anyone to talk to um in part
you'll see your earlier point about
customer service right you know that
that itself is a dishonorable system
even um largely in companies that are
themselves trying to be honorable right
look the first step to solving this
problem is admitting that
we have a need for a constitution-like
entity that declares our right not to
have this happen to us right and that we
are therefore uh we are entitled to
devices in which this is impossible and
those who breach it are
uh committing a crime and uh and you
know obviously in some sense this needs
to be global but so you know so by the
way those who would say well this
doesn't apply the constitution doesn't
apply here so what are you complaining
about well then we have discovered the
reason the constitution or something
like it needs to apply needs to be
invented needs to be widely deployed
immediately because we are clearly in
need of it right which is why the
principal uh our hanukkah principle says
that you need skepticism of ancient
wisdom because the point is our
constitution is effectively ancient it
did not envision the technological world
we would live in it did not uh
understand the
the possibility of corporations that
would uh be more powerful than nations
incredibly forward thinking like such
amazing predictive power and yet
it's just too old to be fully up to the
task of right now right the values are
right but the prescription is it's not
wrong but it's inadequate to the full
scale of the problems i would also point
out though that something i haven't
really seen explored is for there to be
a corporation that generated this very
expensive and highly effective exploit
which can be obliterated apparently in a
single update of the uh the ios software
there has to have been a market that is
to say the kinds of people who have
enemies
apparently know that they can buy access
to their phones enough that it happens
either that or the nso group is
approaching people and saying we have
information on people who don't like you
would you like it and here's the price
somehow there's a world of people that
is effectively trafficking in our
private information and doing so on the
basis of our political perspectives or
our scientific viewpoint or who knows
what it might be but it's a it's a very
frightening world and and they once once
they have the data they can parse it
however they like
right and the fact that this is not
uh that this is a news story among many
rather than a hey what effect is this
having on what news i even know about
right that's the level we need to think
about this
how has this affected the world that i
live in what would the world look like
absent this force to what extent has
apple eliminated
one such entity and there are others
still playing this role yeah you know
these are all important questions yeah
okay um
total change of topic unless you were
you're not done well i just want to
again emphasize that that autumn is
coming
sorry it's a day it sort of seems like
it's here but we're actually getting
summer back next week so i think the um
the equinox may actually bring
summer-like weather yes by the way if
you are confused by what i just said you
are probably in the southern hemisphere
and this will make a lot more sense six
months from now
so we've been doing a lot of
a lot of media nothing mainstream except
uh you know four minutes on on dr
carlson you were uh
two nights ago i guess um but entirely
podcast space really
um and
and have been you're having a lot of fun
with just these highly variable
conversations but with doing a lot of
them and there were three in particular
that we either did this week or came out
this week
all of which prompted some thoughts that
i think are relevant to the kinds of
things we talk about here which you know
is to say
it could be anything right um
uh
let's talk about michael shermer first
okay uh so michael shermer is i kind of
should have looked it up but um he's you
know the founder of skeptic magazine and
i think there's a skeptic foundation too
as well
and um
the podcast is actually um the michael
schumer podcast but it's all you know
sort of of a type
and um he is famously skeptical of um
you know bad thinking in pseudoscience
and such
and we had a very nice conversation with
him i think we actually had the
conversation maybe a couple weeks ago
but it came out
day of publication maybe tuesday of this
week
and um
and his just his announcement of it of
our conversation which uh i think he
even announced it before the
conversation itself was out
um so no one could even see what it was
that we had talked about the number of
people who came at him with how dare you
talk to these two
um they are um you know quacks
scientifically illiterate doing damage
you know all of these things
all the usual tropes all the usual
tropes um from that section of the
internet that um seems to get off on
hating us
came after michael shermer for having
had a conversation with us
and it revealed in part
go go on well i clearly want to say yeah
i do um
we are watching a phenomenon that we are
so familiar with unfolding in a novel
place right and so what this looks like
from our perspective is cancel culture
pure and simple
and the tropes are the same right what
they do
is they inflict costs on people for
certain crimes that decent people
realize aren't really crimes right like
talking to people that you don't agree
with right
so you will be stigmatized for what's
called platforming for having a
discussion with people about with whom
you don't completely agree and frankly
who do you completely agree with right
or for going on someone's show whom you
don't completely agree with right
exactly so i think actually right now um
glenn beck's show is actually is
actually streaming we had that
conversation in person with him a little
over a week ago
and i mean he begins the conversation
with
we wouldn't have been in the same room
together 10 years ago right we thought
we were complete opposites
and the fact is that we can come
together as human beings and see our
shared humanity one another and
how is that bad for anyone right it's
necessary and smart people know that
it's necessary and so we watch
uh
they just drive your costs you know
they're trying to drive up michael
shermer's cost for even talking to us
and part of the point is to punish him
so he won't do it again and part of the
point is to warn others so they will see
what happens to michael and think i
don't want any part of that it's easier
for me just not to talk to them right so
this is this is about shaping the
discussion it is the thing that creates
the walls between these echo chambers
and makes it impossible to solve
problems because you really don't
understand the thing on the other side
you see it as a caricature so it is the
thing that facilitates bad thinking
and um it's obnoxious but i want to draw
a distinction right so
you mentioned our haters of which we
have some very dedicated ones right um
there are some you know uh
people like michael shermer who's not a
hater but he is an influencer and the
haters have gone after him in order to
shift the conversation so it doesn't
contain uncomfortable truths that they
cannot field and so that we cannot
navigate our way to a better synthetic
understanding and then there is this
vast group of people who feed each other
right and they are constantly posting
things to each other and and uh i've
begun to think of them
as the wank and file
um oh dear
yep that's just how i i file them in my
mind
the wank and file um so they know who
they are and we know who they are
but anyway we need to pay attention
because what's what's surprising about
this moment from our side of the camera
is the degree to which things that two
years ago all sorts of smart people
would have agreed were absolutely
obnoxious and had no place in
discourse the heterodox community of
people understood that guilt by
association was a dangerous trope that
prevented the kinds of discussions we
needed to have well some of those
heterodox people are now engaging in
this behavior and so anyway
everybody who is needs to step back and
think wait a second have i become that
thing that i hate yeah
basically
if you are engaging in the cancel
culture du jour it is no doubt because
you are certain that you are on the
right side of history
but if you have previously decried the
idea of cancel culture because
it is clear that you can't ever know if
you are on the right side of history
well then you are acting hypocritically
and you are probably
stuck
somehow in your own thinking you may be
just dead wrong on exactly the topic and
which you were claiming so loudly and
you might not be
but you are at the very least um not
honoring um
not honoring the very principles that
you have in the past said that you would
be standing by yeah um
it is not safe to cancel in the middle
of a pandemic i would point out that's
just a
dangerous thing to be engaged in and
anyway many people ought to know better
yeah
um
okay
so i also wanted to say and i don't know
that you will be able to say much about
this because um you weren't part of the
conversation but um
a friend of yours for a long time jim
rutt uh had had me on his show the gym
rat show to talk about the book um
because he likes to have one-on-one
conversations
and i know him a little bit um but not
very well and you and he were really
kind of you know along with uh jordan
hall and jordan green hall and you know
a few other people whose names uh might
be familiar to some listening um were
you know really present um to help form
game b it was i mean it was an informal
small group of people you know as a you
know gosh i want to say 10 you 10-ish
years ago now i think it was 2013. okay
so eight eight years ago um
and
um so so you and he and you know indeed
we um the very first i think the very
first paragraph of the acknowledgements
in the book we acknowledge gem
um some of we acknowledge some of the
many evolutionary biologists who stole
whose shoulders we stand on and um and
uh some of whom we work with directly
and some of whom we just know um from
their from their written work um but
then we also talked specifically about
um game b and jim rutt and that was
really work that you did together and so
he has me on his show to talk
um about the things that are most
interesting to him in the book and it's
and it's of course right in his you know
his wheelhouse is the theory and that's
much more you know to the degree you
know you and i are both evolutionary
biologists this is our book these are
our ideas
um but to the degree that there are some
that are you know that started one place
rather than the other the theoretical
stuff is more often likely to have
started um with you and in the in the
case of many of the things that jim
brought up um in those conversations
with him
and so having um having me be the person
um
on the receiving end of these questions
was
fascinating and i admit that at first uh
when it became clear that's where we
were going i thought okay
let's let you know let's see you know i
you know i was i was we were writing it
together and we were thinking it
together but um it's not as native to me
and it was wonderful i actually have
listened to part of the conversation now
and um i recommend it um highly we've
got a lot of these out but i really
recommend the conversation that i had
with jim because it does go deeper in
the theory than almost any of the other
conversations we've had
you know it doesn't go into any of the
applied stuff it doesn't do sex and
gender or sleep or food
but the the reason i bring it up
specifically is the benefit of
flying solo sometimes you know we talk a
lot about how necessary it is to have
someone who you know will be honest with
you no matter what
with whom you can um develop ideas who
will have your back all of that
and it's also utterly necessary to step
aside
sometimes and say okay well i'm on my
own you know no one's got my back here
there's no there's no net underneath me
and um let's see what i do
and to emerge out the other side
uh intact and um and saying oh yeah okay
did it got it nailed it um mostly you
know sometimes not sometimes yes uh is
incredibly well it's kind of revelatory
um and it's also empowering in a good
way and i was reminded of actually the
first field season that i did in
madagascar
that you weren't with me for
and i did have a field assistant she was
10 years my junior and i was not you
know i was in my 20s so she mean she was
fabulous
uh jessica but um she was not a peer in
the way that you were and she you know i
was teaching her evolution and we were
you know learning about these the sex
lives of these poisoned frogs together
um but
doing
hypothesis generation and prediction and
experimental design and uh formal
observational design and um and figuring
out you know how to do the actual field
work all of that in you know on my own
without a peer
without that field season there might
still be a piece of me that wondered
could i you know could i do it without
you know just being able to throw ideas
back and forth well i can i did and uh i
would say that everyone no matter how
expert you are in your domain should
look for those opportunities
um to explore things um that you have
typically done with someone else alone
as well
yeah uh it's a really important point
and it also fits with what we discuss
about the way ideas uh
get
passed between people and then parallel
processed and that's really the whole
point of the exercise in the first place
yeah um it makes thinking better and
it's really you know it's very
cool to have you interacting with jim
jim somebody i tremendously value
uh it i think it took a little while for
us to understand each other he sort of
comes from a conservative
uh background and uh actually i didn't
say anything about who he is so he's
yeah he's the former director of the
santa fe institute right um and um
didn't he invent the word
snail mail snail mail that's jim
um epinephrine it is unfortunately the
thing for which he is most famous oh i
should have said it then no no i was
gonna say it myself okay um yeah he uh
he invented the concept of snail mail um
and well he
invented the name obviously yes no the
mail had existed for some time it was
originally delivered on horseback it's
just not that old right you're just not
that old um but anyway jim is a jim is a
great guy and he's somebody i uh i
frequently go to to talk complex systems
stuff um and continue to talk game b
right i mean this
we need something we need this right
well you know what i what i sometimes
say is that the thing about game b which
was you know
effectively a small group of people who
met and then disbanded is that for many
of us once we had seen the idea of game
b and understood what it was and why it
needed to exist then we never got over
it there was no getting over it the
point is it's game b until until we
figure out how to do it or
die trying right because
the system isn't sustainable it's going
to be fatal to us if we don't replace it
and uh
once you spot why a better world is not
only possible but that there's a
mechanism for getting there that doesn't
involve
wishing it into existence
uh it
you know the question is what version of
it and so and you know it only has to be
one version our version is described in
here fourth frontier is the the view
into it but everybody who is of a game b
mindset has some version of it and only
one of them needs to work um and
so far as people i've met everyone who
has an idea of what game you might look
like recognizes that prescribing a
blueprint won't work
and so there are various
routes and plans and ideas some of which
will be inconsistent with one another
but um i at least i haven't seen a bunch
of you know maps of the territory to
which we're going that are inconsistent
with one another because the people who
are thinking game b style are not
mapping out the future they're trying to
figure out how we can get on our way to
a future that is
you know sustainable and productive for
all
well i believe
jim will tell me if i'm wrong about this
he has a very good memory for these
things but i believe that that was uh an
insight i introduced into that
discussion was that we need to give up
on the idea of a blueprint it's
impossible what we need to do is think
in terms of prototyping and navigating
because that's the only way to solve a
puzzle like this and
um anyway to the extent that that has
caught on i think that's good it makes
all of the efforts more likely to work
yeah um
but anyway yes uh tim's a great guy i'm
really i have not heard listen to your
conversation yet but i'm excited to hear
it there's a lot there's so much going
on no and really it's just um
there were just a number of questions he
asked me that if we had both been on
camera
we both would have just defaulted to you
answering not because either of us think
i couldn't um but because it's more
natively the kinds of things that in
your downtime that's what you think
about and i you know i'm more likely to
think about
lizards
right exactly i'm not against it there's
not actually a lizard back here much to
my chagrin but there's a book on lizards
there's a couple books on legends yeah
snakes tadpoles yeah brett made this
pile
um
uh
i was just saying some of the other
things that brett has made this pile in
order to exactly show the screen again
for those listening there's a pile of
books behind me and uh
brett made the pile um but as usual put
the books on bats on top yes
i actually just took the pile of books
that was sitting by my side of the bed
good one light reading on tadpoles yeah
yeah no you didn't know you probably did
not know that there was an entire book
dedicated to tadpoles but if you had
known that you might have imagined that
i would own it and in fact i do yeah
i think my next book might be dedicated
to tadpoles dedicated to towels but not
on tadpoles right yeah no it's
definitely not going to be i don't know
that's what pulls the world future and
past yeah i don't i don't know that much
about i know a little bit about tadpoles
but not enough for a book yeah i think
we probably will not do a future episode
dedicated to tadpoles although i i could
feel an hour
you probably could oh for sure yeah for
sure
um all right
um
and finally ish um in terms of things
that i was prompted to think about from
some of the other media we're doing
about our book um yesterday we did a
live conversation with the awesome guys
at trigonometry uh constantin is it
kissing
kissing kissing and francis foster we've
both talked with them before
i had a great conversation
with jordan peterson with them early in
the summer and we went on to talk about
the book and other things
and i was struck at one point it was
fabulous and i'm sure it's available now
it wasn't just live and then disappeared
no one does that
we were talking about the state of
higher ed higher education and we were
talking about the state of the west and
specifically the enlightenment and
enlightenment values
and
there was a moment at which you said
something that struck me as i get i get
exactly why he's saying that but that
may sound inconsistent to those um who
are not as familiar with what we're
talking about um
which is to say um
one moment you said we cannot fix
excuse me we cannot fix the existing
institutions of higher education we're
going to need to reformulate something
and then you said we must fix
um the the west and by which you meant
enlighten enlightenment values there is
there is no burning enlightenment values
to the ground um whereas institutions of
higher ed um appear to be unsavable and
um how is that not an inconsistency yes
i said something more colorful about the
academy effectively being like our
cherished family dog that has caught
rabies and there being only one
reasonable thing to do in that case
um you did yes i'd i'd
blotted that from my head you had
blocked that out too colorful um well so
it's like this
we don't have an alternative to the west
we can upgrade it but we don't have an
alternative and if you abandoned it
you're creating a vacuum into which the
alternatives to the west will flow in
right if you think you're going to make
uh racial equality
uh flourish by destroying the west no
you won't because what will flood in are
things that are uh backwards with
respect to racial equality and have not
made the gains that we have very clearly
made in the west right have we done
perfectly no but we have done well and
what's more
we have understood the principle to
which we must aspire right a colorblind
society is the objective do we have a
colorblind society no
um are we a lot closer to a colorblind
society than we were in 1950 yeah we've
made great progress
let me just add here and this is a
clarification you made actually in the
conversation on trigonometry uh when you
say colorblind you don't mean pretending
that race isn't real you aren't you
don't mean pretending that people don't
have different colors that they're
reflecting on their skin and people
don't treat them differently as a result
right you're saying um that just as
under the law men and women are equal
under the law and in all of its
instantiations um people of different
races need to be
entirely equal right
and i don't understand why this is even
a hard concept like how how did the woke
manage to convince us that there was
some problem with colorblindness right
the color blindness is actually well i
mean i think it is a i think it is a
conflation of those two points honestly
i think it's uh it is but it may be but
it is a willful one right because it is
effectively an allusion to this metaphor
blind justice right she's not actually
blind it's a blindfold right the point
is it is a it is
an object that keeps her from paying
attention to these details that she must
not pay attention to because they are
not germane to the rights of the person
being tried right yeah so the point is
yes you want a colorblind society which
doesn't mean
we don't talk about think about notice
race it means that it doesn't play a
role in our decision-making process it
doesn't count for you or against you
that's the objective right
so in any case i guess my point would be
we know
that the and i am not in any way okay
with the failure of the academy but i
guess the point that i made to uh to
constantine and francis was
you and i have been fighting that beast
since the 90s literally since we were
college students right yeah they didn't
yeah we faced the post-modernist
yep loons we faced in college or before
we had graduated college
people knew it was a problem but they
didn't deal with it at the appropriate
level they they coddled that insane
world view and they gave it department
after department and it finally took
over the academy it's not the only
problem with it you've also got
markets having effectively wrecked the
capacity of the research apparatus to to
tell us what we need to know rather than
what we want to hear now is that
universal probably not probably it
doesn't apply to you know
radio astronomy or whatever but where
there's money to be made
the corruption has i have no faith that
it's uh that anything is immune yeah i
know i i don't mean good guess i'm like
i don't know how that's gone haywire but
i bet it happened but it probably has
gone i mean if math is having trouble
agreeing on what two plus two equals
then probably radio astronomy is not
immune but yeah um but the point is look
the thing didn't get this way overnight
if it did we could say well let's
let's set it back to where it was three
weeks ago and you know try not to make
that error again but this has been going
on for decades and the point is the
system has not shown a capacity to
immunize itself it has breached every
department that we know of
and so
the thing that we do know and now it
lives in hr which means it's um it's a
it's a cancer that probably can't be cut
out right it's the rabies now here's the
point
which no we don't think it's cancer just
to be clear
right
i like rabies because
i don't know because no you don't yeah
no i like rabies as an analogy here
because the point is the diagnosis you
know it's not the case where your doctor
is going to tell you a nice story about
how we have lots of ways
to treat this right um
there is in the way once yeah once you
start showing symptoms it's a death
sentence you're done so right
so all i'm going to get at is this we
actually know what the problem is with
the university system there is nothing
that stops you from booting up a new
university except for the obligation to
plug it into the same thing that wrecked
the university system that we've got
right accreditation grants uh student
student loan system so that system is
the conduit through which the epidemic
of stupid will flow into your new
institution
so you have to boot up an institution
that doesn't have that conduit and then
you're going to suffer the cost that
conduit was built for a reason it was
built to keep people from creating uh
institutions that would threaten
it's basically a i actually i don't know
that i don't i don't i don't know it was
originally yeah but it has become it has
become that yes yeah
and you know go back to our
conversations on xero being a special
number the point is it is the
accreditation system and the grant
system that means that you can't just
say well everybody should want to send
their kid to a university that isn't
suffering from an epidemic of woke
because those kids will come out more
capable and therefore they will succeed
in the job market and that's what i want
for my child so where is that
institution and you know if it doesn't
exist surely the pressure to build it
must be immense right
so the thing that prevents that is the
uh but you won't be able to you know
avoid phds because you'd have to plug
into this other system in order for
those phds to be recognized and you
won't be able to get money from nsf or
from pell grants right from anything
else and my point is that's a bad
problem but it's not an unsolvable
problem right at the very least in some
sense the recognition that a phd has a
meaning because it comes from an
accredited institution that that
agreement can break down when people
realize hey the people i'm seeing with
these phds don't actually know anything
and maybe i want people with these other
degrees that don't have familiar letters
in them but when i talk to those people
they're not crazy
so yeah no i mean
anecdote after anecdote flows into us
and you know just you know yesterday i
guess we had a very smart very
successful
uh
scientifically minded entrepreneurs say
that um he
he
is seeing applicants to his company with
all of the relevant degrees from mit and
such
and is having a hard time wanting to
hire many of them right because they do
not have the ability to problem solve
among other things and how could it have
been otherwise right of course if you're
going to load all of this ideological
nonsense into the analytical content of
curriculum you're going to come out with
people who can't think straight even
even in engineering at the elite
institutions right maybe especially at
the alien institutions but even in
fields that where they should not have
been able to encroach at all
so in some sense the um answer to your
question of why my two different
positions are not inconsistent is that
the things that are being compared or of
a different nature right it's like
saying
you know if you
uh if you were a hedonist and it turned
out that it didn't make you happy right
being a hedonist being a hedonist you
could swap out your ideology for a
different one the way we can swap out
this academy for a next-gen academy okay
right that's different than
uh
the west being a problem where if
effectively the west is like your body
right and the answer is you know i'm not
happy being a human and it's like well
you're stuck with that right
there are some who would disagree they
may disagree all they want and they may
even disagree with fancy phds that don't
mean anything because they came from
institutions to talk them to think crazy
but corrupt doctors who are willing to
do surgery on them right but no but my
point is we don't have a choice with the
west right we can disagree over how
functional or dysfunctional it is but
the objectives that it lays out are
more or less correct to the extent they
are not correct they can be improved and
to the extent that it doesn't achieve
its objectives we can fix the underlying
mechanisms but the alternative to it is
going backward right it is going
backward into a world that meets those
objectives less well that doesn't honor
those values and
anyone who has seen the comparison i
think would have a hard time preferring
the alternative and so it is
this naive desire to tear down the west
because you think something better is
going to emerge and it you know what it
is
it is exactly like the comparison
between
well the earth is in trouble but there's
mars and we can terraform it right it is
always going to be
massively harder to to make mars
habitable than it is to fix earth no
matter how broken it is yeah so you know
we have we have to fix the west and and
address the problems but we also have to
recognize how amazingly successful it
has been
not only in generating productivity but
improving the quality of life even for
people who are unfairly treated by
in obliterating the bigotries of the
past it has been amazingly successful
and yeah it's not done but that's hardly
an indictment of it
absolutely
all right um
we wanted to say a little bit about um
what this week has felt like um as our
as our as our book launched it's been
it's been amazing and so last week um we
were still a few days out from launch
but um but our episode with joe rogan
had aired and so we'd already made it on
to the amazon best seller charts we were
at like number 15 16 something like that
and we were neck and neck with that very
very very hungry caterpillar
um he remains insatiable i believe as
far as i can tell um and i know i know
you guys have been waiting for the
update on how the caterpillar is doing
um we've been in conversation uh with
some of the caterpillar's people or
actually it was we can't tell if it was
the caterpillar's people or his
butterflies uh they wouldn't go on i
don't think caterpillars have people i
think you think you probably i know but
you know we they wouldn't go on on um
video call with us so we don't know um
but uh we're tentatively moving towards
a de taunt with the caterpillar and
we're even hoping for a collaboration in
the future possibly and i was thinking
um i mean we haven't actually talked
about this but um
something along the lines of maybe the
caterpillar who feels like he's growing
but isn't and that's better for everyone
maybe or um chesterton's caterpillar why
skipping the squishy phase and going
straight to flight is an error
yeah yeah that's all i got at the moment
as possible collaboration
uh hunter gatherers guide lessons for
the hungry
all right cool i'm gonna have to mull
that over i had not actually thought oh
maybe you weren't present on this those
calls no no okay it wasn't it was just
me trying to figure out those people
your butterflies i'm talking to
right okay um yeah no i'm done okay so
uh here's the thing amazing stuff
happened since last we spoke um
the uh
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century on day of launch uh we don't
have a screenshot of this it's on my
phone actually but zach you want to show
the screenshot of the present status of
the book
there it is number three on amazon's
all-around bestseller list yesterday
it's been almost the entire day at two
as it did on day of launch
now this is amazing i don't think that's
true uh it reached number two late on
day of briefly yes briefly and then
spent uh all of yesterday or almost all
of yesterday at number two in any case
obviously the particular number doesn't
matter very much what's really
interesting though
is
that the book has done this well despite
the fact that the mainstream outlets
have not been interested in discussing
it which tells us something it tells us
something really important if we read
those tea leaves correctly
because what has driven this
is
podcast world
right that's where this book has been
talked about and it has been
really uh interesting enough to people
that they have ordered it in large
numbers in fact amazon is out of them
there are more coming they're sold out
um but we know that there are more
coming because
because we have a relationship with our
publisher our publisher is fabulous and
they assure us that they're they're
scrambling to get that second print run
done and yeah it should be there soon
but in any case something is afoot
right that legacy world
right the legacy world which is usually
the place in which books have been
discussed and in which books are made
and broken and all of that stuff that
world has in this case been bypassed by
the unofficial podcast
lower production values
real conversations that are unscripted
between people that can go on for hours
and hours with much more time to you
know make errors but also expand on
ideas and
give you a sense of what the thinking
might be like in the book right right
and so
some episodes back
we talked about the fog machine of war
and the fog machine of war was about the
fact that in order to prevent progress
from being made it is important to keep
you from knowing how well you're doing
right in other words if you're
succeeding in changing things but you
don't know it you won't navigate very
well and so in any case this is i think
a demonstration
that the podcast world which you know we
joined
sort of late um but anyway that world
has incredible power relative to the
mainstream
world and
you know there's a question uh i do
wonder what will happen this book is
clearly uh a bestseller there's a
question about
whether that will reflect in the
official world and if it doesn't
then that's clearly an indication that
bestseller doesn't mean bestseller well
let's let's hope that it does yeah we
don't we don't know the answer to that
we don't know but uh but it will be
interesting to see but i mean it does
i think
you know there is a place for
um highly scripted high production
values uh media but there is clearly
also a place
and maybe just take the production
values thing out of it because um you
know some podcasts are extremely high
production values
but
there is also a place
where for that kind of media where there
is time for unscripted conversation and
yes it is certainly true that our lives
now allow for you know many of our lives
allow for us to listen to long
conversations in a way that might not
have been true 20 years ago or 50 years
ago
and so the technology has happened at
the same time that lifestyles have
allowed for for people to listen but it
also absolutely reveals that there's a
hunger that there's a hunger for uh to
listen to people talking
off script
making errors you know saying you know
as i just did
but
but thinking through real thorny
problems in real time and not simply
using talking points
this is i mean this this i think is the
big message people are just you know
exhausted maybe
fed up maybe but just done with being
fed talking points all the time people
are actually capable and smart and able
to take in information that sometimes
disagrees with one another that's what
you're supposed to be getting in school
right like multiple sources of
information that don't aren't in
agreement with one another and then you
figure out what it means and how to make
sense of it that's what critical
thinking is
that's you know that's what a liberal
arts education is supposed to give you
that's what a high school education is
supposed to give you so the idea that we
you know do and we don't do that in
school much anymore
but then to have the media say
we know that you all are too dumb and
not interested anyway
in uh in thinking for yourselves so
we're going to give you the idiocracy
version well no most
most people don't want that they don't
and i think that's what's being revealed
by um by the fact that the
non-mainstream media is actually able to
um draw in enough people that you know
our book of which we are you know
incredibly proud and we would love if
the mainstream media would talk about it
as well but is you know near the top of
the charts on amazon
after less than a week and and nearly no
mainstream media mentioned yep um i
think it's almost an exact analog to the
point about the academy right because
what happened and you know we know some
of the early pioneers in the podcast
space
but what happened was
people who were fed up with the garbage
that was coming over their screens
were bold enough and visionary enough to
put something onto those screens that
they knew couldn't compete and you know
i'll say again it's the production
values and even the high production
value stuff that we see the discussions
because they're free-flowing aren't
scripted as you point out um shows up
all the time people make errors they go
back it's not like
you know the evening news on the
teleprompter right it's not like the you
know the edited uh
book review in the times it's a
different kind of mechanism it's much
more human and authentic almost by
definition
and you know what it is
it's a bit closer to campfire
it is campfire and uh you know it's not
ex the point is it's it's new campfire
right campfire was an actual physical
thing around which people gathered right
it had a glow this glow is different and
the way we interact with each other is
different and best not to fall asleep to
it right um but
you know i guess the point is a
it's a little bit game b isn't it
um and b it's a lot like what has to
happen with the academy and it's a pity
because the academy is so you know so
many of the elements even still of the
academy are top-notch the production
values are great right they've got
marvelous real estate it sends exactly
the right message their libraries are
full of books some of them even good
right you know so
the point is yeah it would be great if
the academy would wake up but i'm not
holding my breath on that one and what
we have to do is the equivalent of what
podcast world has done to legacy media
world um with respect to education
because frankly no one's coming to save
us right we have we have to educate
ourselves and what that means is
we need a new academy yeah excellent
well um
is that it i think so all right um that
that i think is it for the week
uh we will be for those of you watching
if you want to stick around for a little
longer we'll be taking a break as close
to 15 minutes as possible uh tech
um
whatever the tech will let us do um and
then we'll be back with our live q a and
you can ask questions
at it's not up there is it um we should
put that on the screen it's at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh and i guess maybe and and please like
the channel um on both odyssey and
youtube both this and the darkwas
podcast clips channel and maybe instead
of going through the rest of the stuff i
usually go through here i would say um
if you haven't uh please get yourself a
copy of the book um we've heard that
there are weights at libraries but um if
if you can't or or don't want to buy it
get a copy from the library and and read
it and we are interested we're
interested to start hearing and we have
already begun hearing what people are
thinking and that's you know that's
that's what we want we want these ideas
out in the world
um more than more than anything so
all right
before you get to our sign off yes i
will say
autumn is coming make sure your leaf
blower is in good condition you do not
want to be caught off guard
even if you live in an eighth floor walk
up especially because even a few leaves
can mess that up for sure
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
you